and we are now joined by magnus carlsen
after winning the first day in the final
congrats magnus
uh thank you very much so uh a fantastic
ending to the day obviously
um in this final game let's take that
first are you sort of feeling a little
bit
lucky after that you know when we were
analyzing we did see
some troubles going through it oh yeah
for sure
um i was being being outplayed at some
point
uh after he went knight e2 for some
reason i was
hallucinating uh lines where i could
drop the knight into
to d3 i was only thinking of rook d8
first and then
and then the knight going there but i
mean there's nothing there's no knight
d3 queen e4
um not anything so this means that
that you know my my pieces are being
pushed back
and i am um
that you know i'm just going to be much
much worse
probably losing i was seriously
considering just going knight b3 giving
up a pawn
um but i mean it's a pawn for
for nothing so i i tried to
uh sort of hold on move by move
um and uh yeah he gave
gave me one chance to get back in the
game uh when he went
uh when he went for um for f3
um and uh yeah
after that i think i took my my chances
decently um i was thrilled to to
exchange two light pieces for
for a rook uh not necessarily because i
thought
i was doing great objectively uh i just
thought my position would be so much
easier to to play now
uh and even though i just had i don't
know 30 seconds
uh i knew that he was running running
down the clock as well
um and we'd probably have a have a
scramble where
i'll i'll i'll be doing well uh and yeah
then
you know it was one of those days twice
he he collapsed in
in um in in these
complicated situations uh another day
um on another day i might have been been
punished and well i guess obviously this
this was a must-win situation for hikaru
so it must have been like game three
that was sort of the big
win for you so if you're not too happy
with your play in the last one how are
you feeling about your play in the third
one
well i'm happy except for the fact that
i blundered a bishop
uh but uh
it was it was a fun game that's for
that's for sure
and i'm decently happy with the way that
i converted
the queen landing although yeah i
probably could have been more accurate
there as well
um but in general it was one of those
days where i think neither of us were
like absolutely at our best uh but
we had great great fighting spirit uh
and i think that's
that's uh at the end of the at the end
of the day and the most important thing
you mentioned magnus you blunted a
bishop uh how far into the variation
had you foreseen when you played bishop
takes pawn here was it a calculated risk
or had you genuinely missed something
no no i i just missed queen e7 to d7
so um i because i've been looking at
at bishop b7 on on the previous move
instead of rook to a to d1 and here it
works tactically
um i was just worried that he would take
because now e5 if queen e7 queen d7 i've
i have rook e7
um
um but then yeah so i went rook d1
and then i was only really calculating
the lines with de5 and e4
because i thought i sort of already
established that
you can't take the bishop from the
previous line and i'd even
i'd even seen the line um
queen e7 ed6 uh queenie
queen e1 that i can just take
take that um take the rook
and after he uh secures my my queen i'll
i'll take it
uh and then i'll promote the pun
um so it was just a very very
bad mess on on my part fortunately
i still had a playable position you know
that's the way it is sometimes when you
have uh vastly superior positions
sometimes you can blunder and still be
okay
well magnus you are so close now to your
first tournament
victory and the tour how excited are you
about tomorrow now
yeah this is the closest i i've been uh
i've i think i had a couple of
uh two twos against wesley
in these finals where i i i was up one
game and then
lost the last one on the on the first
day uh this time it was pretty close to
happening again but
yeah i got i i got over over the hump
and uh
i'll try just to um
to to be solid tomorrow uh
not score any own goals and then try and
take my my chances if i
if i can find them well talking about
goals all our viewers are wondering
magnus
was it the real madrid game you kept
sort of glancing at
during those two last games i can't say
it could have been well
i mean talking about football magnus we
know obviously that you
got together with some friends today and
played football which is a big sign of
the world just
getting back to normal to be able to
just hang out with friends and play some
football how much have you been missing
doing that
um very very much uh so it was was great
to
um uh to be able to to to gather some
people and
um and run around a little bit yeah
fantastic yeah what will you be doing
tomorrow uh
to prepare beforehand magnus will you be
preparing some backup openings will you
be
playing football again probably not
football again
uh i'm too old to to play every day now
um i i think i'll try and
um you know check some of the some of
the things that happened
um today uh i mean i did have prep for
the first game but in the other games i
was more ringing it a little bit so
um i'll yeah i'll try try and
um and and be fresh and be
uh yeah work work on some of those
things
all right we wish you the best of luck
tomorrow magnus it's going to be
exciting
yeah i hope so thank you thank you for
joining bye